yeah you know when to welcome to this
video playing debo mater ok supplying
some night a 3g three that can transpose
to basically anything okay school 5 can
be Kings Indian attack and English still
[Music]
jumpy for for the closest almost close
to Syrian Knight c3 okay so probably you
for based set up it looks a lot like
close Sicilian white might play yeah
something like that maybe he's going f1
immediately let's see can I cheeks make
sense now
I don't have a really good square for
the bishop maybe we should be six year I
mean the night on F form is pretty okay
so yeah maybe I can prepare some b5 and
disposition looks very comfortable for
for white this Plus this situation even
though it looks like with Knight f3 g5
h3 and then taking it looks a little bit
like he lost some time but it isn't
failed really okay so i definitely will
take this I just wonder probably
immediately with this I would absolutely
like to play Knight f5 I think I should
play maybe this night oh I thought I
didn't expect okay I think this trading
here should help me night f5 people
definitely pinned me
maybe just this c3 mmm I have to go to
be five I guess nine f5 from byzance
isn't great yeah the night doesn't print
out to p5 that much is clear write them
well I have to go back to c7 and go from
there I don't mind to play a five
strategically speaking with there can be
all kinds of I don't think he can
sacrifice them no I he cannot second f5
and after 97 he also has to watch out
for this pawn on d5 I was thinking
bishop age three and then try to be
brutally a hit on a five but doesn't
feel like it should work no I wanted to
go there anyway Queen f7 preparing this
yeah now I can can trade some stuff I
don't know if it's good though my night
looks a bit wrong maybe maybe I can get
it back into the play like / be the via
before
yeah if T pawn to d4 is what i am what i
expect the night isn't great down it
really isn't
hmm
d 7 25 is probably stronger he wants to
play night maybe Bishop f4
wait wait wait wait just a second yeah
okay
interesting okay I cannot take the form
hmm i'm a bit unsure here how to play
can get a knight to e5 but i don't know
if it is helping all that much it's kind
of doubt for what this actually
threatens this night reform might just
be a check and pretty empty check check
maybe it doesn't help much maybe it does
so I'm checking our teachers immediately
rookie seven
I can maybe just know I think he I
thought he could take and take a seven
which he could do it wasn't impossible
[Music]
30 seconds maybe do six wins now i have
f 3 this is important my children okay
if I take this now Bishop cannot save
himself save itself I'm not threatening
Queen f2 what kind of nonsense am I
doing here that that's crazy I'm not
even threatening anything oh my god ah
Wow ok black resigns it wasn't that was
rather difficult to use this game but
you can always manage you can always
manage yeah ok so here this is a fairly
normal position i think as i said i
thought why does a bit better he helped
me with playing 95 just trading stuff is
helpful for me yeah then ensure well
dear blog is just fine no I Bishop takes
you three I wind ok ya b3 look bad but
as I didn't look for tactics ok yeah
missing those kind of things just costs
point Sam it's it's just winning after
the ship's III but here i mean i should
also be fine why am i not fine
because I'm playing badly right take
stakes 95 is good and again 95 is good
why is that a big difference if i take
first huh check King h3 what's better it
seems yeah and here that's not easy at
all and of course I can take here I just
had a completely Lusa nation this is
very likely a drawing cause of the open
Kings the engine kind of confirms maybe
it finds something better which check
somewhere and that should be a draw with
the Kings that open that's a draw you
know yeah i just had to totally loose
ination them ah yeah of course I can't
takes you three men b3 look bad but I
just didn't look for tactics I was just
thinking that whole day for b3 is
strategically bad but i just didn't
check for stuff like that so it's pretty
much ends the whole thing because white
structure is also completely down the
drain and i have the e-file know ok
thanks for watching